merci monsieur le président je veux
presser si vous aviez constater qu'un
collaborateur ou quelqu'un qui est
proche président lors de ce déplacement
porter une arme auriez-vous ses
objectifs prévenu votre ministre de
tutelle le miz l'intérieur pratique
personnelle alors mais c'est le préfet
même si j'avais constaté qu' une
personne était porteuse d'une heure
alors que à mon sens il n'y en avait pas
le rôle je n'en aurai pas rendu compte
j'aurai effectué un contrôle je pense
que j'aurai interpellé la personne ou
demander aux forces locales de vérifier
pourquoi cet individu était porteur
d'une arme
mais clairement parce que pour moi armes
égales forces de sécurité intérieure ça
s'arrête là donc si c'est un individu
que je ne connais pas je le fais
contrôler parce que potentiellement pour
moi il est une menace si cette année
individus que je connais je je vais m'en
étonner et je vais je pense qu'on aura
une explication
oui parce que la question de monsieur
wattebled du président pas de classement
et en tant que responsable ce que le
président quelqu'un qui a vu nombre et
on le sait on le voit votre rôle et je
suis actif là c'est pas dans le cas
actuel
auriez-vous prévenu l'autorité pour au
moins que ça se sache
bref vous seriez vous opposer à ce qu'un
collaborateur du président de la
république
la compagne en déplacement avec une arme
je m'en serais étonné je pense pas que
je me serais adressé au miso l'intérieur
je pense pas que ce soit du niveau de sa
responsabilité je vais m'en serais
ouvert au chef de cabinet directeur de
cabinet au secrétaire général de la
présidence de la république ça me semble
plus adapté
n'ayant jamais été confronté à cette
situation je peux pas vous en dire